[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'essentiel les magazines
qui reprend toute l'actualité de la
semaine au département
[Musique]
un jeune sur huit est victime de
harcèlement physique au moral le conseil
départemental des jeunes a initié une
matinée de sensibilisation au
harcèlement et aux réseaux sociaux au
sein de l'hémicycle du département
accompagné par l'éducation nationale et
la police ces jeunes auront désormais
une mission de prévention au sein de
leur collège le harcèlement nous
concerne tous
dans mon collège il ya des personnes qui
se font harceler je sais qu'il y en a
qui sont complètement déscolarisés dans
ma classe même est quelqu'un qui ne
vient plus parce que il subi du
harcèlement
même si on ne peut rien faire lui enfin
c'est très compliqué à parent c'est de
parler de leur parler à eux et de parler
aux personnes éventuellement qu'il veut
mais les harceler mais c'est sa vraie
mkii compliqué les jeunes participent
ils veulent montrer vrai vraiment qu'ils
sont là ils veulent ils sont à notre
écoute
mais ils veulent vraiment que on les
écoute aussi on doit c'est un vrai
échange un vrai partenariat programmes
menés jusque jusqu'à la fin quoi jusqu'à
ce qu'ils puissent jeudi des volets de
proposer dans tous les cas là ils ont
besoin de bons donneurs de leçon je
dirais mais et nous nous devons être à
leurs côtés pour les accompagner
l'artothèque de saint denis présente sa
nouvelle exposition machine rouge des
photos et des vidéos de l'artiste karl
kugel transporte le visiteur dans un
monde aux multiples facettes
à découvrir jusqu'au 5 août mon idée
avec ses expositions c'était de
présenter différents niveaux de deux
réalités différentes
différents niveaux de réalité de ce fait
de ce pays
et pourquoi donc ce type machine je fais
référence d'une part évidemment ce
regard c'est mon gars donc ces machines
qui est ainsi je fais référence au fait
qu'une société c'est aussi comme une
mécanique une une société aussi c'est
une mécanique tourne dans le cheminement
que nous faisons avec des artistes
nous accompagnons l'artiste et je tiens
aussi
dire que sur le projet de mandature des
résidences d'artistes
on a accompagné les artistes qui ont
répondu à des appels à projets on le
suit dans son parcours et à travers
différents dispositifs
à travers cette course qu'on met en
place pour permettre la réalisation de
cette résidence mais aussi à travers
l'achat d'oeuvres la 10e promotion de l'
académie des dalons de la plaine des
cafres présentent leur nouveau court
métrage un film de sept minutes trente
sur les difficultés de l'éducation
parents terre
c'était très important on voulait passer
un message par rapport à l'éducation
parce que peu tout le monde est concerné
et très peu de personnes en parlent donc
donc là ça me tenait à coeur de par
notre passé et
académie des dalons c'est très important
parce qu'à un moment donné mais les
jeunes peuvent se poser se remette en
question se retrouver en tout cas une
dynamique et surtout je dirais pas
résoudre
en tout cas vous prendre confiance en
soi et puis repartir sur de nouvelles
bases
surtout avec les outils et le travail
important et le professionnalisme de 2,7
de cette académie et c'est pour ça que
nos jeunes en sort grandi à la réunion
ils sont vingt-quatre mille
bénéficiaires de la reconnaissance de la
qualité de travailleur handicapé
le président du département s'est rendu
dans les locaux de la maison
départementale des personnes handicapées
cyrille melchior a tenu à saluer
personnellement les agents de ce
dispositif de service public en charge
de l'accueil et l'accompagnement des
personnes handicapées et de leurs
proches à travers les bureaux à travers
les dossiers on se rend compte un acier
cycle mokili à d'activité qu'il ya une
évolution mais derrière tout cela il y
encore une fois du personnel et ce
personnel ici avec des péages fait la
démonstration que là il ya une
application est vraiment cette
application de fait plaisir parce que ma
qualité de président du conseil
départemental
j'ai le devoir et la responsabilité de
faire en sorte de la prise en charge du
handicap soit le mieux assuré possible
et je considère qu'à travers justement
les statistiques elles travaillent que
j'ai vu ce matin que cela est bien fait
et je ne porte pas une fois que les
encourager à poursuivre dans cette voie
le bonus de cette semaine c'est une
rencontre à communauté tamoule célèbrent
la nouvelle année 5119 les fidèles ont
préparé des offrandes et ont revêtu des
habits neufs pour respecter la tradition
nous sommes allés dans cette boutique de
saint-andré qui regorge d'accessoires et
de senteurs en provenance directe down
il y a un paquet de coffre il ya du
tissu il ya de l'encens le bâton
d'encens et du parfum
du simple dames c'est la poudre père
fumer il ya du coup kum
c'est le rouge voiture de l'eau de rose
l'adul e-boutique c'est l'assemblée sur
le front une sangle à nice pour brûler
et quand ça arrive c'est une grande
pièce de tissu de le symat 50
et puis de souvent mais
at you lie c'est un petit os très court
qui se portent avec sa vie il ya une
couleur particulière pour le sol on peut
les faits pour les fêtes non oui enfin
il ya cette dame fait par exemple à la
fête de karl et on va prendre du rouge
pour la fête de marjah mais nous
apprendre du jeune biche
[Musique]